foreign
let's project ourselves we are
a mom of three kids and we have
the oldest one's six
and I'm a dad
we can pick you can be the mom I'll be
the dad vice versa
um I've put on 15 pounds over the last
few years
um I I hate the phrase I hear is I want
to get my body back right after kid
number three kid number four
so much garbage out there dude we talked
about another show about influencers and
The Tick-Tock ofization of fitness and
weight loss and dealing with food and
Trauma and culture
husband and wife team they're sitting
there they got three kids kids are in
bed and look and say we I want to feel
better
um you started snoring I want to sleep
better I just want to show up better I
want to get our sex life back we want to
change some stuff
what's two or three or four things like
where do they start yeah no there's so
much nonsense that's good now it's gonna
be different from personal of course of
course but uh look at nutrition from a
behavioral standpoint not from
um
mechanisms like counting calories and
Counting macronutrients stuff like that
although I think it's important to know
proteins fats carbs and calories because
you want to have that information start
with behaviors first so here's some easy
ones
um
one
try to avoid heavily processed foods
that'll usually result in reduction in
calories by itself you get out of your
house just just just try not to eat them
and don't buy them okay okay that's
that's an easy one here's another one
your studies will show that you will cut
your calories by about 10 to 15 if you
simply eat when not distracted
okay so you don't have to change your
diet
just eat without looking at your phone
or the TV or basically not being present
okay you'll need about 10 to 50 less
that way so eat whatever you're eating
just sit down and eat and focus on your
food
a third one would be don't drink
anything water or otherwise while you
eat okay now there's no magical like you
know fluids with food cause this thing
to happen in the body really what it is
is you just chew your food more and you
slow down gotcha okay you're more
pleasant these are these are all
behavioral things so don't drink while
you eat don't eat while you're
distracted avoid heavily processed food
if you just did those most people
in my experience let's say somebody
needs to lose 20 pounds or so we'll get
like 10 10 12 15 pounds wow over time
just from doing you know a few of those
things as far as exercise is concerned
uh make the foundation of your routine
strength training okay it speeds up the
metabolism it'll organize your hormones
well and it sets you up better on long
term it's a longevity play yeah it is
because
um and I used to do this all the time
with clients if we did it right at the
end of their 30 pound weight loss they
would eat they would be eating more than
they did when they started hmm okay not
less what you don't want to do is end up
in a position where yeah I lost 30
pounds I mean I'm eating 1200 calories a
day my life's miserable like how okay I
got to keep this up forever yeah like
you want to be in a position where you
have room and you're okay and strength
training helps to encourage that okay so
make that the foundation and then I
here's the last one I would say
don't
there's nothing wrong with
cardiovascular training in fact it's
great for health and all that stuff but
don't don't try to burn the calories off
by doing tons and tons of cardio that'll
actually shoot you in the foot it's
actually it so that's like a that's a
that's a shape shifter moment yeah and
this is something I picked about a
decade ago and I didn't realize that it
wasn't in the popular culture
the damage there right yeah now I run if
I go for a run it's for my it's almost
entirely mental health yeah like it
clears right or uh if I go for a long
bike ride it's for my head right not for
conject right but say that again like
down with that that's got we gotta hit
home on that because that's that's a new
thing for folks yeah so let me explain
that right so there was this uh great
study that Illustrated this um
scientists went and studied the uh the
hadsa tribe which is a modern
hunter-gatherer tribe so they live
presumably the way that we all lived
thousands of years ago so uh they don't
have modern technology they don't they
don't even use agriculture they hunt and
they gather okay so for all intents and
purposes they're way more active than
the average Western Couch Potato I mean
the way that they would Hunt is they
would stalk an animal track it throw
something at it injure it and then run
after it until it got tired miles yeah
to oh 10 miles or whatever and then you
got to bring it all the way back yeah
yeah so tons and tons of activity in
comparison to the average uh Western so
scientists through some pretty
sophisticated testing went down and
tested their metabolic rates how many
calories are these people burning every
single day and what they found was that
they burned generally the same amount of
calories that the average Western Couch
Potato burn and you think how's that
possible well it's an evolutionary
adaptation ah their body's done
regulated well I mean there's no way we
would have survived if humans burned if
our metabolisms had us burning 8 000
calories a day
you couldn't you couldn't stalk and kill
that much food you ain't gonna find
anything yeah so your body adapted to
become more efficient now let's look at
the type of activity that causes that
it's cardio yeah lots and lots of
endurance type training pairs muscle
down because muscle is very expensive
and it teaches the body to become a very
efficient with calories thermal
expensive means calorie expensive Burns
a lot of calories yes right first of all
you don't need a lot of strength uh to
have a lot of stamina I mean you look at
long distance Runners right they're very
skinny not a lot of muscle you just need
a lot of stamina and because the
activity itself is calorie expensive
right doing cardio does burn more
calories per time spent than anything
else your body just learns to become
extremely efficient at what it does it's
an adaptation process so if the
Cornerstone of your workout routine for
weight loss is lots of cardio what
you'll experience is initial weight loss
and a hard plateau and then in order to
get the weight to have to come off even
more you'd have to cut your calories
more or increase your cardio more and
then you end up in this like I'm doing
six days a week an hour of cardio I'm
eating 1200 calories I still got 10
pounds to lose what the hell is going on
you just explained the United States in
the 80s and 90s and early 2000s that's
it right there yeah go take a fitness
class do a spin class go run miles and
miles and miles and miles and eat way
less and just stop and keep eating less
and less and less and less yeah wow yeah
that's that's a totally failing
um strategy what you want to do is you
want to build muscle and feed your body
appropriately to build muscle and
through that process the weight loss
looks different starts off a little
smaller or slower I should say mainly
because it's uh fat loss with some
muscle gain so the scale might show
offsets yeah I might show a couple
pounds but in reality lost more body fat
than you gain in terms of muscle but
then as the metabolism speeds up you get
this kind of Snowball Effect where the
weight loss starts to accelerate and
then it becomes uh much more permanent
and I like to use this analogy you know
um it would be like if I had a an
advanced AI car
that adapted to my driving
behaviors so imagine if I got my car and
every day I drove 350 miles at 30 miles
an hour what would my car look like it
would adapt and turn into this like
energy efficient machine now what if I
got in that car and I did the quarter
mile as fast as I could every single day
right yeah I'd get this huge big back
tires and yeah this engine that just
burned a tremendous amount of energy
right so strength training does that and
that's why it's the best strategy for a
modern lifestyle because it doesn't take
much time and it also speeds up our
metabolism and that's a good thing when
first of all that'd be a bad thing 10
000 years ago you don't want to Fast
Metabolism ten thousand years ago but
today food is everywhere yeah I want a
fast metabolism that's going to make it
a lot easier for me to navigate this
this landscape where food is so easily
accessible it's hyper palatable
um that's what that's what I want so
building muscle allows us to do that and
there's other look there's other reasons
why I think strength training is so
awesome uh for the average person I mean
it's the only targeted form of exercise
that lets you shape your body no dude
that's not true because there's a button
on uh
the elliptical at the gym at the hotel
and it says uh tone it's the tone button
that doesn't work that way for um it's
for buns or whatever for like tone yeah
do you know that word tone the literal
definition the real definition of tone
is is a muscle's ability to contract
yeah the fitness industry took that and
used it as a marketing term and sold
women memberships because they were
afraid of building muscle so they said
no don't worry you're not gonna build
muscle you're just going to tone you
know muscles don't do that stupid it's
not a thing no they build with a shrink
that's it toning in that sense is
building to a smaller degree that's all
it is so as you build muscle stupid dude
they feel tired it's incredible I know
that's incredible yeah no I'm just gonna
um I'm just gonna do Thigh Master I'm
just gonna work out I just want to lose
weight on my thighs yeah I know you can
do that now spot reduction is also uh
largely a myth but spot shape lifting Is
For Real yeah so like you could like
shape your butt yeah you could tell I do
tons of shaping on my busting on my arms
yeah that's how funny man you could
shape your shoulders and your back and
your posture and your you can Target
build your body and create this kind of
more shapely looking physique through
strength training it's also very
individualizable
um it's the primary form of exercise for
rehab for a reason you know I could do
strength training with anybody yeah yeah
I can't do running with everybody I
can't do swimming with everybody but I
can use resistance in a way to build by
the way resistance training the way that
I'm you know what I'm talking about is
using resistance in a targeted way to
build strength and muscle
that can be any resistance so I want
people to know I want to be very clear
yes that includes weights it also
includes machines it also includes
resistance bands it includes body weight
and so all those arguments about which
one that's just major into the miners
right that's just yeah like just shut up
and do push-ups or go like do something
yes and it has to be appropriate right
right yeah so if I train
if I train someone that does no nothing
no extra no exercise no strength
training very little is needed to induce
any any types of adaptations if I'm
training you know a top level athlete
well it's gonna be a lot more
to get their body to improve any further
and I want to say that because one of
the biggest mistakes people make with
all exercise is they think the harder
and the more sweat and the more sore
they get the better that's actually not
only is it false it's the opposite